investigators are learning more about
this gunman his name is Steven paddock
as you know they search for a motive
Jeff the gazes in Washington with a
Clues emerging from his background Jeff
good morning a lot of questions here
there are good morning investigators
have been deployed across the country
searching for information about the
gunman what they found so far suggests
that few people really knew Steven
paddock and how much of a threat he
really was we're hunting down and
tracing down every single clue that we
can get in his background
authorities say uncovering Steven
paddocks motive is their first priority
no religious affiliation no political
affiliation no he just no paddocks
brother Eric says there was nothing in
his past that would explain his rampage
a retired accountant turned high-rolling
gambler paddock made millions from real
estate investments across the country
when I was very forward up front about
he was a professional gambler and that's
how he made his money on one gambling
trip he slipped and fell at the
Cosmopolitan Hotel in Las Vegas and sued
the casino at the casinos this weekend
he used the idea of his girlfriend 62
year-old Mary Lou Dan Lee who had worked
at a Reno casino for three years
investigators don't believe she's
involved but have questions for her when
she returns from Tokyo the scary part of
that is knowing that he was transporting
all those guns all that ammunition back
and forth right in front of our house
owners of at least three gun stores in
Nevada and Utah say they legally sold a
total of six firearms to Patek including
a reported handgun two shotguns and
three rifles he was visiting all the
local firearm shops as what he told
everybody paddocks father was once on
the FBI's most wanted list
the FBI described Benjamin paddock as a
bank robber who was psychopathic and
considered armed and very dangerous but
with only a parking ticket on his record
Steven paddock wasn't on law enforcement
radar as someone to watch Isis claimed
responsibility for the attack but so far
US officials say they have not found a
link between paddock and international
terrorist
be honest now she said investigators
still hoping to get some answers from
his girlfriend when she returns to the
US Geoff thank you